hey
so here we are really shaping the hands
all right so here we are really shaping
the hands
I'm going to do it in slow motion
first that one that does doesn't go off
into Oblivion that's got to have a hook
on that
because that's going to hook and lead
him
into that
so both your hands now are going to be
very gently
sorry
very gently it's not going to just now
fade off and do this one or else what
happens is you get a gap where you're
standing still you stand still and all
of a sudden you jump for a gosh
where if you do it where this hand thumb
goes down
you've always got contact
thumb goes down thank you I'll change
over to the other hand
now you won't be so smart
it's good because I kept seeing these
thumbs you know you must have really
thought about that sound because I kept
you know they jumped out at me so that
was really nice okay let's see how we
get on with this one